your afternoon show man you already know
been telling you this dude is coming
he's finally here swizzy Showtime that's
right SS beats in the building man
you're fresh off a airplane too right
fresh off that thing right here from NY
from New York this the the weather is
amazing here even though when I left New
York the the weather was good too but
here is like amazing this is you can get
tan out out here yeah hey lots of
congratulations in order to man
congratulations on the new baby thank
you thank you congratulations on the uh
signing with scam artist yeah scam time
hey shout out to Swiss man a lot a lot
of people know you started off as a DJ
right yep started started off as a DJ so
now it's like full circle yeah man just
just following your dreams and just just
doing what you what you feel like you
having fun with that's what's up now um
on the production tip you're the man I
know you know that say I'm I'm I'm still
working hard man yeah so what what are
you working on right now I know we were
just talking about um the Jay-Z and
Kanye album watch for the throne you
said you were working on that oh man I
got some fire on that album can you tell
us about like the name of the joints
what you know what I'm saying I don't
even know I don't even know the name of
the joints cuz like when we working we
just like focusing on just making
history right like as far as the names
I'm sure him and Jay will figure that
out later how many tracks uh do you have
on that on that album right now it's
like two-ish 3ish two-ish or three-ish
two-ish 3ish it might be 4ish fiveish
when I get back though that's what's up
are they recording it like overseas
still they all over the place H we was
at a at a um super lowkey low
that's what's up you know it was pretty
different for me but I was like I you
know music is music is you can make
music anywhere yeah me and juicy were
talking about you and uh of course you
worked you know with
DMX C you know uh we were curious like
like Cassidy yeah what's up with Cassidy
I've been looking for Cassidy too you
too yeah cuz he had like two extremely
slapped on albums and you know he just
kind of disappeared and I know you were
working with him so I don't think the
albums just slept on he definitely did
his numbers I think I think after those
albums um his potential to to to take it
to the next level was slept on yeah yeah
and then um of course DMX who's you know
one of the illst but like you know it's
always he's you know I'm from Phoenix so
I see DMX all the time he's always out I
mean I I say DMX is theis you know why
you know why I say that you know um
there's not an artist that I've seen
that that tried with his fans 50,000
fans and and really touch the fans on on
a non you know
I don't even know on a non-traditional
level like really going and touching
people's hearts and you know being able
to represent the have not you you know p
i mean Pac did it but Pac didn't even
like cry with his fans on stage like ask
like every you DM I remember I saw DMX
at the hardlock knife tour in a and that
was like it was crazy and he does that
every show you know what I'm saying so I
mean like he end he used to end his show
with a prayer and he used to be you
could drop a a pen and his quiet and you
can head in the stadium are you I know I
know um you dropped what was that song
time to get paid you did with them
recently yeah that's U monster Monday
joint yeah yeah yeah yeah are you are
you still like you know is there still
chance DMX and swi beat dropping more
music together or it's all on him it's
on him it's everything everything any
you know I'm open for anybody that want
to work as a part of the family you know
just like Eve you know that's why I put
on my first singer every day you know
just to let people know that the album
is crazy and that I'm still you know a
part of the rough r of roots and it's
not going nowhere long yeah I was happy
to see that I was like I ain't seen e
for a minute yeah yeah her Alum was
crazy we working on something special uh
new artists out there's a lot of new
people out right now that are you know
that are bubbling is there any new dudes
you're checking for that you want to
work with um I want to work with I like
I like Bruno Bruno mods I think we could
do something crazy together the homie
whiz um Ross new artist Meek Mills yeah
Meek Mills dope um man like all all them
dudes you know you know they doing
positive stuff so you know and they
hungry I like like that yeah have you
have you heard this dude Frank Ocean
yeah Frank Oceanic Frank Ocean too you
know the whole our future click all that
yeah yeah and then you were saying too
um off the air you saying that you're
going to be working with your wifey on
on some music too right yeah I said I
was working with Jay's album I mean the
Watch the Throne be's new album my wife
new album my new album that's the stuff
how was the baby doing man he's good
he's
good that's what's up little Egypt
that's your the baby's name is Egypt
yeah that's what's up before and we
named him Egypt before like everything
even happened in Egypt and it was like
wow what he like he's you know he's
going his name is like yeah means
something now for real went like to to a
whole another it meant something when we
initially did it but it like went to a
whole another level you got like the
like you got such a such an amazing
catalog of music that you produced man
and um I always wonder like what's
what's you probably don't have one but
what what was like one beat of yours
that sticks out as your favorite beat
that you made I always say stopped drop
because it started my career yeah you
know like that that that track right
there and that song right there let my
presence be felt around the world and
it's like I always give go back to that
TR you like 17 yeah yeah that's what's
up that's what's up 17 18ish when you
look back on that on the on the on Dark
and Hell is Hot like I I I still feel
like that's the you so far ahead of this
time but tell me about it man the
passion the passion was in that you know
definitely definitely is there is there
like a um is there a project that you
were on that that like being a part of
that kind of compares to being that
first that first DMX Alum R Riders
volume one you know being that it it it
also um brought new life to the game
yeah just like as dark as hell and hell
as hot you know it brought new life to
the game but then coming with volume one
you know he was able to Showcase you
know like drag with Juvenile and you
know everybody now on the south by but
you know we've been doing that with J
joint yeah jiger was on there um the Eve
song was on there like we broke like new
artists on that Beanie beanie seag for
the first time was on that that's such a
like a lost art I remember when comp
like compilations used to like man they
used to matter now it's it's like
mixtapes you know cash just put out
mixtapes for free you know what I'm
saying I mean cuz you know it's it's we
in a new day and age you know the
equipment is is easy to get you know
people know the formula that's why more
accessible yeah that's like with my
album that's why I went a whole
different way like you probably can't
duplicate this let's talk about your new
album man what is it called when's it
coming out um new album called hope
living you know it means the best of the
best cuz I want to give my people the
best of the best um it comes out on my
birthday September 13th and who you got
on the album I'm sure it's it's a
ridiculous everybody man it's crazy I
got my first single out right now
everyday featuring my sister Eve you
know we starting off cool and I got um
skyscrapers featuring me Bono and Kanye
I got no no you can't duplicate this
album I'm telling you you know then I
got um me Wayne and Lenny kravis on on
the
joint um which is groundbreaking for hip
hop the weight when you hear this joint
I'm sick Mary's on the album John
Legend's on the album um Mia this it's
crazy I know I know you kicked it with
with with uh with Bono to like what's it
like hanging out with with the dude from
YouTube cuz I mean you like I mean like
I Look At You Like A hip-hop dude you
know what I'm saying like I I just you
know growing up I I I've seen you you
know evolve is there a point where like
damn I'm hanging out with the homie from
YouTube right now but I mean like you
know when when I was a part of when when
we started the ref Rider movement i'
been I've been I was doing Rock then you
know I did keep rolling for LM biscuit I
did maryn Manon I just never like
publicized that but I've been like
tapped into the Rock and Rock Community
but Bono is like the funniest person I
know that's what's up he'll come in here
and just crack jokes on everybody all
now um your your ex-wife Monda she's on
this new show I don't know if you I'm
sure you've heard about it the love and&
hip-hop joint M have you did you check
out that show at all I'm assuming you
probably haven't but have you seen it at
all I've seen parts of it what do you
think about like kind of her take on
everything that happened or is that um I
don't really want to get into that but
it's her take it's her take it's her
take there's always two sides to the
story you know what I'm saying it's her
take it's it's three sides it's you know
three sides to the story three sides to
the story yo so we got this side my side
and the truth these dudes um it look
like some hardcore uh tattoo artists
they they they won this competition yeah
I seen On th like man they got to tatted
tatted up crazy tatted up West Side
Chopper looking hey if you want to throw
them headphones on we're play the beat
real quick okay let us know let us know
how you feeling about it real quick
let's see what's up hold on it said
hip-hop tribal on the CDI hope that's
not the name of the
beat that's a horrible name
un oh my goodness here we go the guy's
name is Jeff and they won already yeah
they already won man and see not oh
there it is let's
[Music]
see I can hit Gaga on this
Gaga wait for to hit hold
on juicy Louis fist popping right
now this is some Vegas is right
here I had the
clubs
[Music]
there it is shout out to Jeff out there
who made that not bad right not B it's
not bad at all that I can see you know I
like you said what I want to know is
what they was up against yeah I want to
hear those like what like what was the
what what beats what did I have to
listen to I don't know we had a lot of
beat I thought this was one I was like
okay that ain't bad no no no no that's
the one that won right there so they get
their DJ Hero too yo we're going to have
you hop in the mix right now do what you
do we're going to go to commercial break
yes come right back Showtime you want to
play some uh some new stuff we see what
I mean I got you know we can't play
curses we I don't got a lot of stuff Ed
we going to have fun we going to have
fun that's what it is the newest scam
artist DJ you know what I'm saying SS be
scam time it's coming right back live in
the mix man